oh [__] eighteen hang up now it's gonna
be one of those nights [__] look
at this look at this I got a special mug
you should promote with a [__]
look people so you know enjoy it all
[__] around
yeah yeah this is dipped in [__] oh my
god
look at this [__] thing look at this
[__] you think you're dealing with
tonight listen tell your grandmother
suck a dick you're not gonna rub her
feet tonight you hanging out with uncle
Joey look at this [__] bottle of
death we're taking it back to the old
Jeep I stick a joint check okay I'm with
these these [__] how it's done
tonight
[Music]
you got a bottle of Tito's home a it's
that type of night [__] steel
the grandma I still want a zanuck steel
one of grandmas chemos tablets and
drinking with a [__] cocktail take
you for the next level
[Music]
in solar water you find everything
a little pat benatar circa 83 won the
[__] game he's smoking his albums I
have heard in my [__] life and that's
how it's going down this [__]
tonight oh yeah out [__]
uncle Joey bringing your [__] game even
[__] seen before
look at this shitty we got this today
from the [__] one i jus this that
we're doing it you know what this is if
two grams of reefer with a [__] gram
of hash in there what you do is you take
this [__] string okay let's see you
take this string right here see my
[__] podcast in about how house and
easy you learn something you take this
string out right right the [__] butt
crack and funny's cut okay you take this
off then you take this toothpick out oh
[__]
everybody else is bullshitting you
people if you are thinking about race
foot how to lose your mind and how to
see the devil there's one man for the
answer okay now for you THC enthusiasts
who think you know everything about
everything you take this you take this
because if you hit with the line of the
toothpick hole will burn right through
you're [__] drunk then you want to be
able to suck Nick for a week
say you got a headed slow
[Music]
you wanna rock where you want to keep
[__] around with these Gentiles
telling you huh
I know Terence Mckenna Terence Mckenna
the other one the other one that can all
suck my dick unless you're at the Voodoo
Lounge getting down with uncle Joey you
ain't [__] [__] if you're saying joint
what can I get one of those
you got a perennial tomorrow and you
tell them that [__] uncle Joey sent
you we're [__] around no more you put
I'll seal this in your eyeball and
you'll be walking around are you looking
through the eclipse you don't say I
don't give a [__] what are you gonna do
with your [__] Eclipse glasses now
your [__] [__]
jerk off with them a look at your mother
get the [__] out you don't buy anything
I don't give a [__] you gotta buy all
these [__] and boxes out there
looking at the sunlight [__] jerk
balls when does it end
when does it [__] end people went to
Nashville I know a group that went to
Nashville with little goggles people up
keep it up one minute you looking at
still eclipse the next minute Isis is
[__] in the ass keep it up Thursday
Friday Saturday
I know sad that you gotta stay home and
don't give a [__] you guys are there
taken four hours like usual you dumb
[__] go out [__] your girlfriend he ass
again you got a hotel room for small
sixty like my little sex Oh towels and
[__] your girlfriend the ass you both
get more out of it than watching that
[__] fight that debacle objective
[Music]
with Mack Coleman we ain't [__]
around [__] bong gets reflux it over
yet Lee it's ready we're ready to go
here it's time to try you gotta try
something
it's not that's the kind of weed you
give to [__] people before they take
the electric chair that's it that's the
kind of weed it you're never wrong me
versus you not to what and stars a
blazing understanding when I [__] around
time will coming out the box my [__]
Satanist no water like Papillon like
what a [__] Island we're preparing in
case of [__] Yong Yong Kim throws a
[__] nuclear bomb over here who do
you think something survived these white
[__] that he can't know cockroaches
like me they're gonna [__] survive
I'll be in this office with my little
[__] friends over here smoking
dope seven send and [__] that's right
I called ya Jews of Christ bullets I'm
sick and tired of lying to you people
they killed Christ you know why Jesus
showed up his envelope was like [__] you
walk around with twelve guys on the
right and below doing magic tricks and
that's and not charging that's my
favorite [__] [__] right
there I don't give a [__] what anybody
says you know who's here tonight the man
the legend I don't know what the [__]
you were thinking I know you wanted to
watch a movie and binge watch with your
girlfriend tell your guilting to take a
[__] hike me Burt and the
[__] will come into your
[__] living room right now it's gonna
be one of those nights so Paul the rehab
right now cuz you Jewish you guys like
fire what the [__] it's Wednesday night
who's they night I'm sorry Tuesday night
with I know I can let sue me but we
split it 50/50 that's how real Jews do
we sue each other but then when nobody's
watching I get my check under the table
or he goes to the government we just get
30% and I'm saying that's a scam people
in porn for years I'm sue Byrne eight
times before [__] I died but we'll
both be cracking up cuz you don't pay me
the insurance pays me this rate goes up
my pennies who gives a [__]
[Music]
you people don't know what the [__]
you've got yourself involved a ketose da
is leashed bad why don't you hit me with
those [__] stars you [__]
have no idea what type of night you're
in store for tonight we've been playing
with your last two episodes we knew the
Rogan podcast would be tremendously
we're starting on love we're coming at
you with [__] jabs on the hooks the
whole [__] thing tonight anyway my
heart goes out to John Jones I don't
know what happened so I open up your
mouth look like a [__] [__] so
we'll leave it at that
my heart goes out to him whatever
happened happened
you know last month I smoked the joint I
came up positive for heroin it happens
all the time
people make mistakes I forgot about that
[__] cinnamon bun I had some yum-yum
those [__] got it it's like if
you eat fruit from the cartel fruit you
never test positive for cocaine
don't you nobody knows
[Music]
make it a little hot like the one and me
oh [__] she's my lipstick you better
make sure you put me bleep what's going
on with the stars you know you got ten
more to eat don't worry let's cast like
a [__] mummy understand look at it
tomorrow you're gonna go over there tell
them I was on with Joey I want Kennedy's
hot tamale to [__] grams of weed and a
grandma ass who's better than you are
[Music]
I'm dying
I'll respect with Jerry Lewis I'm saying
there's a Jerry Lewis joint right here
this will he smoked that last day
[__] it that's right he left that
telethon money actually had I not 2.6
billion million
[Music]
and again we don't do your life me I
[__] up mine don't do what I did get a
horse go to the Kentucky Derby do
something with your [__] life if you
thinking getting once I think get a
horse all the time I'm just my horse got
to have some big legs here we go so they
can't be oh [__] oh [__] I think it's
time for liquid acid to mine everything
no indeed currently become one in the
same we started with five as an
appetizer that's just an appetizer Alice
with children was the bag big boy
oh [__] we don't [__] around here you
understand me
we started with fines that was an
aperitif they were having aperitif it's
like a [__] little thing you have
yeah like amaretto Oh [__] Irish
cream that's an aperitif this is when
the main course comes in best one when
you get two spies on the stuck together
you're gonna have a good time
[Music]
delicious 50 grams of THC utopia good
it's vegan free coconut macaroon peanut
butter
the body of Christ compels you you give
this a [__] highway
it's a macaroon 50 [__] milligram 50
milligrams can't do none to the machine
that's early morning and when you hang
out in studios my bad luck we got some
good news for you this is a week for the
one eye - you need to do a pocket you me
need no stars not like that
but you guys go [__] it I saw the
graphic comes in I'm gonna do a little
Tino's myself I'm gonna find that fight
with all the [__] chitchat some about
hey Baca I used to have a friend he's
drinking straight and follow-up letters
drink bottles of it in high school
Bert I call it [__] I used to love
box and Lipton iced tea but then you get
up in the middle of night thirsty and
what's the right seat they almost have a
heart attack
anyway is that type of night w and you
were planning I'm gonna read a book do
some reflecting on my life go suck it
dick
lyoha go the husband on the guitar it's
just let [__] know what
diamonds you understand me
[Music]
but I would just sit there like a
because you did you warm up till I know
you didn't yeah and there you go
tremendous take the poise release it's a
good [__] body
I don't give a [__] who needs a lung I
walk around like the guy who [__]
sons anarchy yeah but two tubes in my
mouth a little bite that'll give me fun
get on me at this point
ain't got time to [__] you people no
more be chasing people to [__] of mine
I'm just some fat [__] see the whole
thing is you gotta mix it with something
else because this is too wet it's
breaking up like [__] a piece ahead
you guys don't have no [__] idea
get the [__] you ain't smoking this bad
[__] mix look at my fingers ever
grease somebody with a [__] yeast
infection you think is get shiny like
you were just busting into a safe once
you wipe off the easy things it's good
for your fingers if you think of
somebody East infection from time to
time it's good for your fingers too lot
of people don't know that it's like a
[__] it's like a human [__] now
it's like going to a Chinese person
without going to a Chinese person I mean
it's gonna get my manicure when I get
the power of Christ compels you
let's put another piece of peel [__]
your world I'm just visiting a
girlfriend of mothers yeah you sure
tip your head back
think about the technique you're about
to do now I'm ready to go here we go
people
we [__] around here whole school
Scott sided talk the police bomb hit of
death here oh my god it's kind of
catching on fire that's perfect that's
what you are let me tell you somebody's
kids what happens is when this hits your
lungs and expand that's why when you
block the smoke here like oh I beat this
I beat this case no you didn't that's
what I sheesh because we don't give a
[__] kid tonight so you got ten minutes
youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz that's the
place to be [__] you better be on
point tonight the great Burke crisis
here the Machine [__] let me talk
when listen when Trump was talking to
the Russians the Machine came up did you
know that that's any day now any day now
that Jared Kushner that half a [__]
son-in-law is gonna come out and say it
was Bert Kreischer who put this together
on a train 10 years ago he started this
conversation
trust me I'm telling you I love you
mother [__] this stay black don't forget
my little brother is wet so tomorrow no
no that's it so he's that Thursday
Friday Saturday and you uncle Joey the
Ontario improv Thursday Friday Saturday
if you snooze you lose don't comply let
me Joey
I call this don't take it you [__] up
you [__] up I got do one more
bungalows and [__] debt
and you want to go to [__] trade
school your dumb [__] now you take the
toothpick in your finger team dat to
fake this toothpick has been living in a
better reefer for the last month my FAQ
teacher did they pay the floss every
night that's exactly like it doesn't
matter what your floss with here you go
don't forget youtube.com slash c / Joey
Diaz be there or be square
oh [__]